lens flare is everywhere it glows on our
supermen near our iron men and around
our method acted oil men it's in the
fifth dimension the final frontier and
definitely the fictional town of Lillian
Ohio the lens flare is a technical
phenomenon and distinct sensibility
that's taken over lens flares can get
pretty complicated
there are countless lenses from the past
century of filmmaking not to mention the
physics involved but a movie fan can
identify flare pretty quickly the basics
are that each lens has a bunch of parts
and when bright light shines at the
right intensity or angle it can bounce
around in those parts that bouncing
produces a bright haze as well as lens
flare the flare shape depends on how
diaphragm blades these things close to
create the aperture which is where the
light gets in if they have fewer blades
you might get a hexagon shaped flare
more blades and it'll be closer to a
circle anamorphic lenses have a
different flare they were designed with
an oval shape to squish more information
on to a piece of 35 millimeter film when
they're projected out with another lens
it's in a wider format and all that
makes lens flares that can be like
stripes of light across the picture but
these flares weren't always so trendy
for decades cinematographers fought to
hide them when Gregg Toland shot Citizen
Kane he and director Orson Welles
innovated constantly famously they used
deep focus to show a lot of stuff
clearly and at the same time they
increased the depth of field by making
the aperture tiny and using really
really bright lights so Toland coated
his lenses with barred optic coat to
reduce glare and lens flare from all
that light and it set a norm in a path
for innovation lenses were constantly
coated with new and better technologies
that helped keep light from bouncing
around and creating flare it also set an
expectation to make an immersive
professional movie you did not have
Flair until a revolution in moviemaking
changed it in the 1960s new filmmakers
wanted to show their movies weren't made
in a box they turned a flare to capture
a documentary like look legendary
cinematographer
Conrad L halls working Cool Hand Luke
was a rebellion that turned into a
movement he even talked about it in 1992
s vision of light the art of
cinematography I feel particularly
involved in helping make mistakes
acceptable if the light shone in the
lens and flared the lens that was
considered a mistake that would somebody
would report that the operator report up
the Sun hit the lens that flared the
lens that cut he showed the heat of
chain gain life by keeping in the flare
and that quickly spread to rebel movies
like The Graduate and Easy Rider
they symbolized authenticity and as a
result lens flares did too just as Flair
helped sell the reality of characters it
could sell a sense of wonder flare
spread really quickly like in 1968
Planet of the Apes and later Steven
Spielberg brought it into Close
Encounters of the Third Kind flare had
entered the sci-fi and action canon if
early flare said these feelings are real
now it could say these spacemen and
explosions are real too and though JJ
Abrams gets slammed for his gratuitous
lens flare use its use as a tool of
realism and wonder has impressed
everyone from schlock jocks like Michael
Bay to true artistes from Sofia Coppola
to Terrence Malick Malick can't get
enough it's in video games political
logos and maybe your phones whether
screen movies in the 60s had to prove
they weren't made in this box and in the
90s they used lens flare to try to prove
they weren't made in this one even
though flares become available with just
a few clicks
lens flare used to be a mistake you
tried to avoid now it's a choice you
can't escape
so you've seen a lot of
computer-generated lens flare today but
all this stuff is actually legitimate
however to get it to show up reliably I
had to place a light really close to the
camera that's because modern lenses have
a protective coating that's pretty good
at stopping flare it's also the reason
that cinematographers on movies like
there will be blood and Saving Private
Ryan have actually stripped away that
coating just so that they can get the
old-school flare look